hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
central issues that Cicero grapples with
in his dialogue on friendship is the
basis of genuine friendship friendship
in the fullest sense and this was a
controversial matter back in ancient
times as it does remain so for many in
our own time so he's asking this
question and he recognizes it as very
important what is the source and basis
of true friendship and there's there's
more than one possible explanation for
this now one explanation that many
people give and this might actually be a
sign that you don't want to be friends
with them is that it's ultimately due to
needing something from the other person
and there's there's good ways to put
this and also you know bad ways to put
this or we might say less positive ways
when we talk about friendships
ultimately being merely transactional or
we suggest that not only two opposites
attract but it's its opposites within
the relationship that keep the
relationship going we're saying that one
person is supplying something that the
other person can't themselves provide
and
that's that's the reason why they're
attracted to each other and that's the
reason why they would stay with each
other and that's the reason why they
would do good things for each other and
that that's the reason why they would
feel goodwill or affection towards each
other which are absolutely central in
friendship now you know we could put it
in terms of complementarity and think
about romantic comedies and all of those
sorts of things though you you find
somebody who's very unlike you and they
introduce some spice to your life
because you're a straight-laced person
and they're the punker
and vice versa you know they get your
the the spontaneous artistic person and
they provide order to the chaos of your
life well sister all would would still
lump that in with this rather mercenary
cynical transactional view on things and
he suggests that there's actually a
better explanation so he raises this
this question and he says the more I
reflect on friendship the more it seems
to me consideration should be given to
this question whether the longing for
friendship
the desire for having friends is felt on
account of weakness and want so that by
the giving and receiving of favors one
may get from another and in turn repay
what he is unable to procure of himself
that's one alternative the way that he's
putting it or here's the other
alternative you know he says although
this mutual interchange is really
inseparable from friendship you've got
to have that whether there is not
another cause an older cause a more
beautiful cause right one that he in
this translation emanates more directly
from nature in in in the Latin here it's
Mogga Sonora it's a Profeta that that it
arises or it's brought to being from
nature out of nature and now when when
Cicero says nature don't think you know
the way that some people frame it today
and this Darwinian
nature red in tooth and claw or what
evolutionary biologists and
psychologists and whoever evolutionary
things wants to frame it because that
would actually be a very truncated
conception of nature that would actually
fit much better in with you well you you
you have friends because of weakness and
want you need to get something from
somebody else and so our genes tell us
to do this or you know it's adaptive
Cicero says no no nature is is faster
and more complex than that you might
think of this as it's coming out of the
very basis of our being which is to some
degree a plenitude rather than a want or
deficit and so he goes on and he tells
us that friendship genuine friendship
not just friendship in terms of
usefulness or even what Aristotle called
the friendship of pleasure but genuine
friendship where we we want to know the
person themselves we want to be with
them because of who they are and we
develop this intimacy where we value the
friend not just for what we're getting
from them but for what what they are and
what we can be in a relationship with
them so he says that in this kind of
friendship there's nothing false nothing
pretended whatever is there come is
genuine and comes of its own accord
therefore it seems to be friendship
Springs rather from nature than from
need and from an inclination and applica
aplicación a of the soul with some
feeling of love sense ooh a Maundy in
the latin rather than from calculation
of how much profit the friendship is
likely to afford and he he provides us
with a number of different
considerations to support this he tells
us first that if we observe even just
animals and then other human beings
which are animals
- we noticed that this this inclination
and this feeling of love or affection is
indeed natural to animals now he gives
you know the commonplace of he says this
feeling may be perceived even in the
case of certain animals which up to a
certain time so love their offspring and
are so loved by them that their impulses
are easily seen and this is the go to an
ancient thought but you know given all
that we now know about animal behavior
and its seeming plasticity you can find
cases of animals brought up with each
other very different species sometimes
not even you know mammals and other
mammals but mammals and birds that
somehow create a kind of friendship
where they they clearly enjoy each
other's company they have something in
common they take care of each other
they show affection to each other you
might think for example of the you see a
lot of these videos on YouTube the one
with the owl and the cat who would play
with each other or you know other
examples you can come up with countless
ones human beings do this in terms of
familial relationships not every family
is a good family of course but he says
there's an affection that we can find
even more evident in human beings from
the affection existing between children
and parents which cannot be destroyed
except by some acceptable crime and
again from that kindred impulse of love
which arises when we met someone and it
will take a look at that in a moment
now notice that Cicero is not saying
that it's an automatic thing this this
affection between parents and children
and it's something that has to grow
nowadays we think of it in terms of
attachment right and there could be
reasons why it doesn't work a terrible
crime abuse of the children neglect of
the children in that case children may
not in fact feel affection towards their
parents or they might feel the kind of
tragic affection which will never be
satisfied and there are some parents who
are genuinely horrible parents probably
shouldn't have
kids but in in most cases I think we can
say that that we see across cultures
across time this impulse there and
Cicero says this comes from nature it's
even more so in the case of people he
says who's who share with us some habits
and nature and and the word for habits
there is Maurice motor boss actually
here quiesce Komori boss at night hora
con guru ammos right and so that this
this notion of agreement or a
commonality come guru Loomis we we are
congruent literally in it we are able to
be on the same page with so we feel some
affection towards them now you might say
well okay so bad people like hanging out
with other bad people they could be
sharing in all sorts of bad habits and
and maybe people have a bad nature and
Cicero says really this this works the
most when we're talking about good
people when we're talking about those
who have virtue and those who have a
kind of uprightness and he uses this
word Probie toss there as opposed to
some of the other vocabulary that we
might expect to see in the Latin and and
uprightness rectitude doing the right
thing
honesty these are all sort of synonyms
for each other so when these people
appear to be upright and virtuous then
we are attracted to that he says that we
we see in our friend as it were a sort
of lamp of uprightness and virtue and
then since rule goes on and he says
something that I think a lot of people
might find kind of controversial there
is nothing more loveable than virtue
nothing that more alert us to affection
since on account of their virtue and
uprightness we feel a sort of affection
even for those we have never seen he
says is there anyone who does not dwell
with some kind
the affection on the memory of Gaius
fàbregas and Mattias courteous though he
never saw them like us if we if were
interested in them and he goes through
another set of people who we hate even
though we've never met them Tarquin the
proud spurious Casius or spurious my
leus looks like the spurious must have
been problematic right and he even talks
about again against two leaders we had
bitter struggles for the empire of Italy
Pyrus and Hannibal now this is
interesting these are two people who
were sort of the big baddies the enemies
of the Roman Republic Pyrus was was
somebody who we don't know very much
about typically although we can look at
his biography if we want to because of
the word pirate victory because he threw
in so many troops and and lost so many
troops in in winning that he said
another victory like this will lose me
the war Pyrus was in a place called the
Pyrrhus and he had sort of world
conqueror ambitions he was modeling
himself after Alexander the Great and
you know he was one of the people who
went down in the history likewise
Hannibal was the great Carthaginian
general who almost did defeat Rome and
you know famous for taking elephants
across the Alps but even more famous for
being a brilliant strategist and the the
two of them he says we can look at them
in opposite ways Pyrus we like because
of his uprightness we don't have any
great hatred for him we actually admire
him Hannibal we hate because of his
cruelty so those who we don't even know
but we see as virtuous or vicious we
have a natural response of loving or
hating them we could think about our own
time think about all the media people
that we encounter in our day to day life
we don't actually encounter them we only
encounter them virtually and what we
encounter is a tiny tiny sliver of who
they are maybe completely different than
who they are
in reality although you know we do have
little windows into that as well but we
have these responses of love and hatred
we would be friends with people who are
virtuous and upright and so this is
something that Cicero thinks is is
natural to us does this mean that it's a
guaranteed thing no because there could
be you know vicious people who like
other vicious people but this is
something that does he says hold for the
most part and a little bit later in the
work in in chapter 14 he also talks
about virtue knitting together
friendship and he says that if there
should be some exhibition of shining
virtue to which a kindred spirit may
attach and adjust itself then when that
happens love must need springs forth and
he talks about you know how silly it is
that we love all sorts of inanimate
things and then you know wouldn't love
another person and he says that it'll be
granted as the fact that good people
love and join to themselves other good
people in a union which is almost that
of relationship propinquity us and of
nature
he says for there's nothing more eager
or greet more greedy than nature for
what is like itself so when when we are
attracted to those in whom we see some
modicum of virtue it's in part because
we we do in fact like virtue but it's
also because that you might say the
virtue that's within us however however
developed or underdeveloped it is is
responding to what we see in the other
person doesn't quite work the same way
with Vice there can be a superficial
liking but vices are things that we
actually don't like about ourselves and
usually don't like in other people as a
matter of fact other people can
sometimes be the mirror for what jerks
we are and how much moral development we
need to to undergo so Cicero thinks that
all of this happen
by way of our human nature rather than
simply some calculation or transaction
so the basis of friendship is really
something natural the basis of genuine
friendship
you